gone sucks he really does he's selfish
morally great kind of pathetic ability
wise and generally a detriment to
everyone around him hello and welcome to
the new world review your source for
psychotic pre-teens my name is Liam and
this is something I've wanted to do for
a while I have mixed feelings on gone if
this character were a cocktail then he'd
be made up of one part standard Shonen
protagonist one part crippling hypocrisy
one part daddy issues and two parts of
very very angry little boy depending on
who you speak to gong could be one of
the most love shown in protagonists or
one of the most profoundly hated and a
lot of this has to do with the fact that
he is a child which is not at all a rare
thing for a Shonen series most of its
protagonists are children and or young
adults which is just a fancy way of
saying children but among them gone may
be the most realistic incarnation of
what would happen if you put a 12 year
old in these sorts of extreme situations
not everyone is a Goku or a Luffy or an
aster and generally kids in these kind
of situations and they're probably not
going to turn out too great gone is not
an inherently good or a bad person it's
sadly not as simple as that because
gone's own Simplicity prevents that sort
of designation the best way I think I
could describe gone and probably any
pre-teen is that they are a blank slate
it's very easy for us adult folk to
judge what actions are right or wrong
according to a stringent code of
morality or societal rules that we've
developed over decades however when it
comes to the mind of a child
distinguishing good from bad it's
surprisingly not that easy that's why
they're children because they're still
learning the things and in that way I
would actually strongly compare gone to
Maryland both of whom were completely
inexperienced children things struggling
to Define their place in the world one
began in your most standard nurtured
human upbringing whilst the other was
brought into the world with the mindset
of a violent ant creature also this
video is sponsored by the ants
underground Kingdom the world's first
ant-based simulation strategy mobile
game available on the Amazon app store
where you can save up to 25 on apps
games and in-app items using Amazon
coins I mean really have you ever
wondered what it would be like to become
the all-powerful ant king well in this
game you get control of your own ant
hill to serve as your base for
exploration and building plus it
features a funky gacha system for
hatching hundreds of special ants and
you can even learn their real habits in
game they're all simply waiting for you
to discover cultivate and form the
ultimate ant Army plus this game is so
damn smooth featuring stupidly high
quality graphics and an art style that I
would describe as both elegant realistic
and cute I said both but then I said
three things well I'm not taking it back
this game has over 35 million downloads
and you can plus one by clicking the
link in the description but in addition
they've also prepared some wonderful
gifts for everyone if you enter the
following coding game gifts are nice so
do that thing but for now it's back to
you me one began in your most standard
nurtured human upbringing whilst the
other was brought into the world with
the mindset of a violent ant creature
and yet the two of them really aren't
all that different we see both of them
grow learn make choices and in the end
the monster ends up not quite being the
one who it is that you thought it was
you said that terribly but I I'm not
re-recording it which brings us to point
number one as to why it is that gone
sucks which is that he is incredibly
selfish for the most part anyway because
there is something that we need to know
to ride out of the gate in hunter hunter
gone's character is inconsistent and
it's because of togashi's evolving
writing style he did not start the
series with the intent to corrupt gone
and as a result a lot of his actions
during the hunter exam and zodiac family
Arc actually fit quite perfectly into
the standard Shonen protagonist tropes
he is kind caring observant and
generally portrayed as like a second
coming of Jesus Christ because he's
always helping healing and saving those
around him and whilst gone does have a
couple of troubling retrospective red
flags during these arcs his Evolution
came later along with togashi's abrupt
shift in writing from about Heaven's
Arena onwards though gone becomes
problematically selfish one great
example is deliberately disobeying Wing
who told him not to take a match on the
204 for two months so that Wing could
properly teach him Nan and as a
consequence teach him properly not to
die but gone heard this and thought yeah
you know kind of want to punch some
things so he took a match against Guido
lost horrifically and risked himself
becoming permanently injured or even
being killed not for any greater reason
mind you in a more standard Story the
protagonist could still do this but they
would have a much stronger reasoning
behind it like maybe their friend was
captured and they were forced to fight
or they ran a clock and like they'll be
ejected from the 200th floor in 24 hours
so we've got to take action or perhaps
the protagonist just has some serious
beef with the person they agreed to
fight like oh I'm gonna mess you up and
that goes on to teach them a lesson
about controlling their emotions gone
has none of this he was not forced to
fight he had no feelings towards his
opponent whatsoever there was no time
pressure and no one was in any danger no
one except gone who put himself in the
danger but essentially gone just did it
because he got impatient and I love that
because it's exactly what a child would
do gone doesn't understand the
consequences that his actions will have
and really what 12 year old does I call
gone selfish which is a fairly negative
thing but that's a problem for him as a
person however for us as readers and
watches it is quite a unique treat it
makes gone worth paying attention to
because his crippling flaw has the
ability to generate some pretty Peak and
naturally occurring drama like I said in
a more standard series The Hero would
need a more convoluted reason to break
the rules which sometimes can feel a bit
clunky with the wrong author but Gone
Gone is unrestricted by all of that he
can do anything and everything because
he's just a stupid selfish child and
that allows him to explore a lot of
ideas that other main characters are
forbidden from touching on one of which
is the fact that gone falls into a very
morally gray area and for this I'm going
to reference the YouTuber Alexander who
made a video essay on gon's moral
hypocrisy which is a very worthwhile
video to watch but during it Alexander
dwells on one of gon's lines during York
new city where he asks crolo how can you
kill people who have nothing to do with
you and Alexander goes on to point out
how gone became exactly the type of
person that he accused crawler and the
troop of being ah I would never join you
you bad people I would rather die than
become whatever it is you are you
naughty naughty spiders and a lot of
people would interpret this as gun you
know taking a bit of a jab at crawler
more or less to display his moral
superiority and disapproval of crawler's
actions I have a different take though
when God asks how can you kill people
who have nothing to do with you it
strikes me as less of a jab and more
pure curiosity the same way that a child
would ask their parents how babies are
made because they're unaware of all of
the sex and stuff I do think that gone
is genuinely curious and as we would
later come to learn God doesn't have you
know particularly strong moral positions
on stuff like murder one great example
of which is Bernal a very minor yet
extremely important character within our
journey of gone despite being a
cold-blooded serial killer he gets put
in an almost tragic situation where he
is tortured in a hole for 10 days by our
protagonists I'll say that again our
protagonists caught a man and tortured
him for 10 days in a hole all for the
purpose of making gon and kilo are
stronger it's okay though because penult
he's a piece of [ __ ] right well no
actually I made according to gone yes
yes it is okay but also according to
gone benalts is a pretty cool dude after
getting as much out of his victim as
possible gone thanks Bernard gives him
an honorable bow and even refers to him
very respectfully as Bernal son
ultimately letting him go despite the
fact that doing so could endanger the
lives of countless people because again
Benoit is a serial killer that is the
terrifying magic of gondo his childlike
mind is either so pure or maybe so
sociopathic that he doesn't see the
issue with that because spinault helped
him I mean against his will mind you but
because spinault helped him that makes
gone appreciate him and if that's not
morally gray then I don't know what is
and like I said before there were red
flags all throughout Hunter Hunter like
when kilua ripped out that dude's heart
and gone's response was you know what
I'mma make that guy my best friend yeah
again though this is not a bad thing not
at all the fact that gone has no clearly
defined morality Beyond whatever seems
to serve him best in the moment makes
him infinitely interesting to follow
because it makes his actions and future
story developments very difficult to
predict and reason number the third why
gone sucks is because he is consistently
outclassed by almost every other
character in Hunter Hunter this is
probably where gone sucks the most as a
main character he is almost always the
weak Link in whatever group he's a part
of his best friend kilua is light years
ahead of him karapika swiftly advances
Beyond anyone's expectations bisky and
kite their obvious veterans and even the
more rookie Hunters like knuckle display
a clear dominance over anything and
everything gone is capable of throwing
at them not only that but gone does
admittedly sometimes have good battle
sensors but more often than not he
seriously fails to judge the situation
correctly gone is nion incapable of
reading his opponents instead always
choosing to launch straight into battle
which almost always leads to dire arm
losing consequences and the reason why I
love this is again because it is
realistic a 12 year old with no combat
experience who just learned Nan a couple
of months ago would get absolutely
trounced by even the lower tiers of
power in this world and as a result that
makes the world of Hunter Hunter feel
very intimidating because we're looking
at it through the lens of someone who is
simply ill-equipped to deal with the
overwhelming challenges thrown his way
like you see this duck this duck is
every opponent gone faces in Hunter
Hunter and as a result every time a
fight started I felt a genuine sense of
dread because I knew that gone might not
do the classic thing of power up or
think of a clever idea to get out of
this intimidating duck situation every
fight gone engages in presents a
scenario where he could and has on
multiple occasions being permanently
injured or even fatally wounded and I
like that gone's fight history in Hunter
Hunter shows just as many losses as it
does wins perhaps even more now to be
clear gone does have some or shall we
say natural benefits tossed his way with
being a one in a million gifted nen user
and of course being the son of one of
the most powerful deadbeat dads in all
of manga but considering that he almost
sucks even more because he was born into
a natural chosen one-style power and yet
at every turn he still usually fails but
the true genius here is that eventually
Togashi uses gon's weakness that has
been on display throughout the series as
one of his crowning aspects of character
development during the Chimera Antarctic
here gone becomes consumed by his own
weakness and while it is portrayed as a
response to kite's death this has really
been a whole series coming kite was the
straw that broke algon camel's back
before now his shocking weakness had not
led to any serious non-arm-related
consequences but when faced with the
idea that his weakness cost kite his
life gone went on to choose the most
childlike path possible and he decided
to throw a tantrum a very serious and a
very emotantrum but to tantrum
nonetheless and it shows his emotional
immaturity which again he is 12 so this
is exactly the kind of thing that it is
would happen I mean just think back to
your pre-teens every time something
slightly bad happened it was like the
world was ending it was consuming
frustrating and painful and you were
probably incapable of seeing the bigger
picture around it and now apply that to
an event as traumatic as kite's death
and I think that gone's reaction is
pretty damn spot on for his age gone
very rapidly reached a point where his
selfishness inexperience immaturity and
weakness transformed him into a person
that was no better than the Phantom
Trooper even but not gone was more than
willing to kill komugi a completely
innocent person during the palace
Invasion all because he was so consumed
by his own faults and Lust For Revenge
which as we all know eventually
culminates in the terrifying
transformation to adult gone this right
here is the true tantrum where Gone In
the Heat of the Moment decides to throw
everything away his life his
relationships and his ability to use nen
all for the sake of taking revenge
against an androgynous kitty cat and I
know that a lot of people here try to
argue that Gomez backed into a corner
and he did it for survival but that's
not what happened at this point gone
didn't care about whether he lived or
died the only thing he cared about was
cracking pito's head open and feasting
on the goo inside making them pay for
killing kite thus simultaneously
satisfying gon's need for power and in
the only way he could think of make the
situation right for kite and obviously
those happened in her completely Twisted
ways but that is the beauty of gone he's
one of the only shortened protagonists
who has had this option of falling into
complete darkness so much so that in my
opinion he ended up as more of a villain
than Maryland did so what is there left
to say about God well he sucks as does
that he's very simple-minded with that
simple mind generally focusing on
selfish desires he's emotionally
immature as arguably all 12 year olds
are his experiences in life so far have
left him in a very morally gray and
sometimes quite morally black area
despite all of his natural advantages in
life he wonders this world being almost
pathetically weak compared to those
around him and when he finally does
achieve that low-class power it is a
hollow Victory which came at the cost of
everything I mean when I put it like
that it's a really tragic story but one
that I am very glad I got to experience
he's not a hero he's not a role model
and he's not even a great friend to
those he cares about within the world
itself gone just sucks and that's what
makes him such a fascinating protagonist